Salut, c’est Tonton Tarik !
La Tecktonik, tu te souviens ?
T’as peut-être kiffé,
t’as peut-être détesté,
en tout cas,
impossible que tu sois passé à côté.
Je vais te raconter ce phénomène.
Pour ça, on remonte à 2007.
Tonton Tarik a diggé
quelques archives.
La Tecktonik,
c’est monté très haut
et c’est retombé très vite.
Enfin, ça, c’est ce qu’on a voulu nous faire croire.
À l’origine, l’idée,
on la doit à deux Français.
L'un deux s'appelle Alexandre Barouzdin.
Et lui, il sent qu’il y a
un business à se faire.
Au début des années 2000,
il squatte les soirées électro
que ce soit à Londres
ou aux Pays-Bas,
et il va monter une soirée
qui a lieu dans une boîte
au sud de Paris
qui s’appelle le Metropolis.
C’est l’ambiance,
c’est le Metro, quoi !
Leur soirée s’appelle
"Tecktonik Killer".
D’où le nom "Tecktonik".
Le principe de cette soirée,
c’est de mixer
trois genres
de musiques électroniques.
Il y a la minimal.
Le jumpstyle.
Et le hardstyle.
Là-dessus, les clubbers
vont poser des mouvements.
Ils vont s’inspirer
de plusieurs danses,
comme le voguing…
ou le Melbourne shuffle.
Mais le mouvement caractéristique
de la Tecktonik,
c’est les moulinets
avec les bras.
Je me suis demandé
d’où ça vient,
cette histoire ?
En fait, c’est assez simple.
Tu vois les bracelets fluos
qu’on te distribue
en entrée de boîte ?
Quand tu les mets
autour de tes bras
et que tu commences à faire
des petits mouvements,
ça fait
des petits effets sympas.
D’ailleurs, c’est une création
100 % made in France.
Alors, la dernière fois
que les Français
avaient inventé une danse,
c’était il y a 154 ans exactement.
Un siècle et demi plus tard, donc,
la soirée Tecktonik cartonne
au Metropolis.
Mais si vous n’avez pas l’âge
ou la crête qu’il faut,
c’est recalage,
comme on dit ici.
Deux heures de queue
pour rien
et 300 mètres à essayer
de faire bonne figure.
- Il faut avoir la carte,
même si t’as 18 ans.
Ça marche tellement que
d’autres boîtes
vont s’y mettre.
Mais là où ça prend de ouf,
c’est dans la rue.
Là, la Tecktonik
va passer un cap.
On la voit en plein jour,
en plein Paris,
il y a des battles un peu partout,
que ce soit à La Défense,
au Trocadéro
et surtout à Châtelet.
Ça se passe aussi
sur Internet.
Alors, à l’époque, il n’y a pas
Insta, Snap, Twitter,
et compagnie…
Non, à l’époque,
il y a deux choses.
La première, c’est Skyblog.
Skyblog, c’est un site de blogs
inventé par Skyrock en 2002
qui a commencé à bien
se développer en 2005,
et deux ans plus tard, en 2007,
les blogs les plus populaires
ce sont souvent les blogs
autour de la Tecktonik.
L’autre truc déterminant
dans l’histoire de la Tecktonik,
c’est YouTube.
Donc là, le gars,
il s’appelle Jey-Jey.
Sa vidéo fait
un million de vues,
ce qui est complètement ouf
pour l’époque.
Et tout est posé, hein,
on voit
le look, les mouvements,
le son…
Et avec cette vidéo,
la Tecktonik va sortir
de la région parisienne.
Ça commence à danser
un peu partout en France.
Bien sûr, comme ça devient
un phénomène,
la télé commence à en parler.
Voici maintenant un phénomène.
La Tecktonik.
Un peu en mode boomer parfois.
Pour danser,
il faut avoir le bon rythme,
et surtout le bon look.
Ils s’agitent
comme des lémuriens
attaqués par
un essaim de frelons.
Je vous ai parlé d’un des cofondateurs deTecktonik,
il s’appelle
Alexandre Barouzdin.
En fait, il a déposé
le nom de marque.
Et ça, ça lui a permis de lancer
des T-shirts,
des mitaines,
des lacets à l'effigie
de la marque Tecktonik,
et tout ce qui est possible
de sortir
en produits dérivés, en fait.
Ce sont des danseurs que
l’on voit un petit peu partout,
ce sont des soirées dans toute l’Europe,
c’est une boisson énergétique
pour justement donner
la pêche à nos clients.
Puisque ça rapporte
de la thune
et que ça fait danser
les jeunes Français,
les labels de musique
aussi vont s’y mettre.
Universal
va monter un groupe,
je suis sûr que
vous le connaissez,
c’est Mondotek.
Bon, j’ai pas les droits
pour vous passer leur son,
mais j’ai des super collègues
chez Brut,
et je suis sûr qu’ils vont savoir
vous rafraîchir la mémoire.
Dans mes souvenirs,
ça faisait…
Le son, c’est sympa,
mais chez Universal, ils ont aussi recruté des danseurs.
Ils ont réussi à sortir
Jey-Jey de son garage.
Et ils ont recruté
d’autres danseurs
hyper populaires dans
la communauté Tecktonik,
comme Karmapa et Lili Azian.
J’ai retrouvé Lili Azian.
Et voilà !
Elle m’a montré des images qu'elle avait filmées
à l’époque.
Ça me fait chaud au cœur,
je me dis, quand même,
c’est une très belle période.
En discutant avec elle,
je me suis rendu compte qu’en fait, la Tecktonik,
avec Mondotek,
avait fait le tour du monde.
On est partis en Russie,
en Allemagne,
en Suisse,
en Belgique,
île Maurice,
Guadeloupe.
Il y en a qui sont partis
en Corée,
et je dois en oublier sûrement…
Donc voilà, ils sont beaux,
ils sont jeunes,
ils ont du succès,
mais en fait, la Tecktonik,
ça commence à saouler
tout le monde.
Le truc est partout,
c’est l’overdose médiatique,
on en a marre de ce marketing hyper agressif, aussi,
donc, en 2008,
c’est fini la Tecktonik.
Enfin, ça, c'est ce qu’on croit.
Parce qu’en fait,
la Tecktonik n’est pas morte.
Alors, déjà, on ne
parle plus de "Tecktonik".
Ce terme, c’est les médias
qui l’avaient repris
en faisant un peu l’amalgame
entre le mouvement
et la soirée à l’origine.
Vous appelez ça
comment, vous ?
- La danse électro.
- Tout simplement.
- Parce que c’est
la musique électro,
donc la danse électro, voilà.
La danse électro, donc.
On ne la voit plus à la télé,
mais elle est archi validée
par des stars de la danse contemporaine.
En 2009, par exemple,
c’est Blanca Li,
une chorégraphe mondialement connue
qui va s’y attaquer.
Elle, elle a kiffé
la danse électro,
donc elle monte un spectacle
qui s’appelle Elektro Kif.
Donc, là, les danseurs
qu’on voit,
ils sont passés pros,
et en plus, on paye
pour aller les voir
dans des grandes salles
de spectacle.
Au même moment,
il y a un autre élément
qui va faire perdurer
la danse électro.
Ça s’appelle le "Vertifight".
Vertifight, c’est une asso
qui organise des battles
un peu partout en France.
Ça a été créé en 2007
et petit à petit,
c’est devenu le rendez-vous
incontournable
des danseurs en France,
puis à l’étranger.
J’ai pu échanger avec
l’un des fondateurs
du Vertifight,
il s’appelle Youval.
- On peut les applaudir
bien fort s’il vous plaît !
C’est Youval !
Youval et les gars
qui ont créé ça,
ils viennent du hip-hop.
Donc ils ont créé des battles
sur le même modèle
que la breakdance.
En fait, c’était beaucoup
de jeunes de quartier
qui faisaient une danse
qu’on appelait l’électro,
mais ils n’avaient pas
la structuration des groupes,
ils n’avaient pas
les comptes sur la danse,
ils savaient pas danser
sur des nappes.
Ils ne savaient pas
défendre cette culture
qui, à la base,
n’était pas une culture,
c’était une mode.
C’était la mode Tecktonik.
D’un coup, grâce au Vertifight,
les danseurs savent
que leur look
ou leur popularité,
on s’en fout.
Là, ce qui compte,
c’est d’être bon,
de s’entraîner,
d’être agressif
face à son adversaire.
Un peu les codes du hip-hop, quoi.
La culture Hip-Hop,
pensant que la culture électro,
c’étaient des mecs
qui bougeaient les bras,
mais bon, c’était vite fait, quoi,
ils ont pas compris que
pendant 3 ou 4 ans,
ces jeunes danseurs
en herbe,
ils sont devenus super forts.
Ils sont devenus
tellement forts
qu’ils pouvaient se mettre
en face de la culture hip-hop.
Et même, d’ailleurs,
la culture hip-hop,
tout à coup, elle a calqué
ses mouvements sur
la culture électro.
Si un jour elle a les couilles
de le reconnaître.
Bref, grâce au Vertifight,
grâce à Blanca Li
et surtout à la persévérance des danseurs,
eh bien en fait,
la danse électro,
elle est toujours
dans le game aujourd'hui.
Ça, pour s’en rendre compte,
il suffit de scroller un petit peu sur TikTok.
Ça danse un peu partout
dans le monde,
mais la première nation électro, ça reste la France.
Pour en parler,
j’ai rencontré deux danseurs,
l’un de la première heure, Treaxy,
et l’autre qui s’y est mis
plus tard, Miel.
Aujourd’hui, cette danse-là, elle est partout,
que ce soit sur scène,
tu peux la voir avec
Marion Motin,
Christine and the Queens,
tu peux la voir dans Climax
de Gaspar Noé…
En fait, les gens,
ils l’apprécient
et ils ne se rendent
même pas compte que
ça vient des cendres
de Tecktonik.
En fait, cette danse-là
fait vraiment partie de moi.
Quand je la vois dansée,
j’ai l’impression qu’il y a
une partie de mon âme
ou de mon ADN
qui est dans les danseurs
et je le ressens, en fait.
Parce qu’il y a un truc que
j’ai créé indirectement
dans l’énergie,
dans les mouvements.
Et c’est encore ce que
je ressens aujourd’hui, tu vois.
Quand je me mets à danser,
à percuter le son,
genre : ouah, ça me transperce.
Il y a des compagnies,
il y a des spectacles,
il y a des battles...
D’ailleurs, j’ai pu assister
à l’une d’elles
il y a pas longtemps.
C’était au 6b à Saint-Denis.
Ça ressemblait à ça.
Franchement, l'énergie
sur place était assez ouf.
J’ai pu voir des battles pros
et des battles amateurs.
Il y avait des gars
qui dansent depuis le début,
il y a des gens qui sont arrivés
par le hip-hop
et d’autres qui
n’ont jamais connu
le mouvement électro
à ses débuts.
Et quand on les voit danser,
on sait que cette génération,
elle n’aura rien à envier
à ses prédécesseurs.
Franchement, si j’avais arrêté à 14 ans
quand on me disait "ouais,
tu fais de la Tecktonik…",
je n’aurais pas fait
une tournée mondiale
avec
Christine and The Queens,
j’aurais pas fait
plein de campagnes de pub,
je n’aurais pas créé de compagnie…
Enfin, ma vie, elle aurait été
un peu naze, quoi.
Voilà, si cette vidéo t’a plu,
tu peux lâcher un petit like
et t'abonner à la
chaîne YouTube de Brut.
Aussi, si tu as
quelques idées de sujets,
n’hésite pas à les mettre
en commentaire,
j’irai les creuser.
Salut !